hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
for tonight is one of the most content
filled games I have ever played
it's like minecraft mixed with wave and
tower defense and a crazy level of
micromanagement and detail many of the
skills you will pick up through osmosis
but there's a few things that slip under
the net after 20 hours of play I've
barely scratched the surface of this
beast but even in that short amount of
time I found 10 things I wish I knew one
had first started I'm starting with
something which is counterintuitive to
most gamers on most levels you are given
a task to complete such as finding and
activating an Atlas don't rush to it
leave it as long as you can the game
world rewards you for scavenging looting
and exploring so run into the wilderness
and find activities to complete rescuing
survivors thanks again for your house
see you soon
find blueprints to help you craft
buildings which don't look like basic
cube structures completing these will
reward you handsomely by simply
following the design you can build some
really impressive structures this is the
beat yard there are little minigames
defined to and boosters to unlock once
these are complete now's the time to go
to the original task in the world
so remember explore the world you are
thrown into you may find a treasure
chest r2 or something which can be
searched by the way don't destroy
something before you search it or all
that precious loot is gone for good the
stumbling block we all run into quite
early on in the game is locating ammo
resources our integral part of the game
and nuts and bolts are the resource
you're probably running low on they can
be found in many places but the most
reliable way to farm them is by smashing
the stout of the vehicles you see I
suggest going to the towns if you need
to craft ammo as vehicles are few and
far between in the countryside later in
the game a mission named repair the
shelter will ask you to search for these
transparent objects the majority of
these badboys contain up to 400 nuts and
bolts so farm to your heart's content
your first real mission will see you
building a storm shield home base you'll
be coming back here regularly and
whatever you build will stay here
indefinitely so plan what you build and
don't make a huge embarrassing mess like
me if you change your mind later on and
tear everything down it will be
massively time-consuming and it won't
yield many materials in return and as
the game progresses the quality of your
structures the traps you create are
imperative to survival
so always plan what you want to build
speaking of traps if you look closely
enough you will see your backpack has a
limit to the amount of items it can
carry a great way to make space in your
rucksack is to craft numerous traps this
will also keep you one step ahead when
it's time to build defenses just be
mindful of the materials it takes to
craft those
level of your character trying not to
play as one single character as each of
them has benefits and a few limits to
the ninjas double-jump is very useful
when exploring what other characters
have constructing ability and in the
later levels these are essential to
maintaining your structures so my advice
try out a few characters and switch
things up every now and again remember
to level your characters too and improve
their stats and abilities
this goes for weapons too and pretty
much everything else in this game level
it up level of your favorite guns to
improve them constantly eventually each
gun will break but don't worry too much
when you craft another it will retain
the level you progressed it - so don't
save it for a rainy day use it and craft
another one that time is right another
tip I wish I knew early on was the
recycle function when weapons are close
to breaking you can opt to recycle them
the benefit to doing this are the
resources you receive in return you
won't get enough back to craft the same
gun again but you will receive materials
which may be difficult to find in the
open world so recycle to your heart's
content oh and by the way the guns you
crap yourself will have far superior
stats and perks to those you find in the
game world so when you get a new gun
schematic craft it and try it out
furthermore as you level up your skill
tree recycle old weapon schematics - and
other low level stuff you don't really
want such as survivor cards retire them
to make room for higher-level survivors
as well as gain a little xp to the next
tip isn't accessible from the beginning
but once you start to upgrade your skill
tree it will be before each level during
the character lobby screen select your
character and add gadgets to your
loadout I only have two at this point
the first is a health boost to your
character and other allies that may be
in the vicinity and my current favorite
gadget is a freaking airstrike both are
perfect for difficult sections in
calculus
finally building a defense the Cossacks
will take the path of least resistance
trying to get to whatever you're
defending so keep that in mind when
you're creating a mace for them to run
through if you build a fan area too
extensively the enemy will simply ignore
it and your hard work is ruined
give the hook a line to run through
known as funneling then sit back and
watch the carnage
so that's it that's ten super quick tips
when you're trying to get your head
around fortnight and guess what that's
only the beginning
take Florence cabbage before committing
to the task at hand farm
a most BOTS operate absolutely
everything recycle where possible use
your gadgets as soon as you can and plan
your defences accordingly there are so
many more areas to look at in fortnight
and if it's become useful I'll be sure
to create a new video for intermediate
players I need to take a minute to thank
youtuber and twitch streamers hack
office for helping me out on this one
he's in my suggested channels list so
please check him out if you want to see
some fortnight live and he pretty much
plays anything he can get his hands on -
I imagine from PlayStation grenade it's
been an absolute pleasure I'll see you
next time